Stephen Larson is an attorney who
represents one of creepy porn lawyers
former clients he's pushing for Cpl to
be disbarred for what he did he joins us
now Miss Lauren thanks very much for
coming on Thank You Tucker can can you
tell us what about his behavior in your
view warrants disbarment well my view is
shaped by 30 years as a lawyer here in
the state of California I've been a
judge I've been a prosecutor myself over
the last 10 years I've been in private
practice the legal profession means the
world to me and at the core of the legal
profession is honesty trust transparency
accountability to our clients and for
someone to do what mr. avenatti is
accused of doing not just by us but now
by the State Bar of California and to US
Attorneys offices is beyond the pale it
threatens our justice system it
threatens the rule of law certainly
threatens the to shape the public's view
of your profession which raises the
obvious question why hasn't he been
disbarred already I mean just watching
this on television it was clear that the
guy was a fraud in a menace well our
justice system depends on our process
and the process is being played out mr.
avenatti has not been convicted he has
not been found guilty but just this week
the State Bar of California filed papers
seeking to have him move to an
involuntary inactive status they can
only do that when they are convinced by
clear and convincing evidence that he is
a threat to the public or his clients
and they believe that they will be
successful and that the successful lead
to disbarment so it's a pretty unusual
step for the State Bar to take again
that hasn't been decided by the courts
that's working its way through the
process part of our rule of law is
people are innocent until proven guilty
we are confident that that's what the
evidence will show and that's what will
happen but we do need to await the
process has he offered any sort of
defense none we have not seen anything
come forward and he's had the
opportunity to do so in fact we brought
an arbitration proceeding pursuant to
our contract but our client and him we
brought it before jams
we wanted to have the arbitration it
required him to pay the arbitration fees
what he has refused to do we're now
planning to dismiss that and move
forward in the state courts which is our
right to do he's doing from our
perspective everything he can to delay
this again it's within his rights but at
the end of the day we are convinced that
justice will prevail can I just ask you
a broader question I can't resist so you
seem like a man of integrity and a
serious person you've been in a
prosecutor a judge
private practice attorney most people
don't like lawyers not because of people
like you but because of people like Cpl
there are a lot of sleazy lawyers out
there and almost none of them ever get
disbarred distinct Bar Association's why
don't they do something to improve the
quality of lawyers and maybe that would
help all lawyers well there's no
question that we as lawyers and we
regulate ourselves to a large extent I
mean the state bars and hang-up of
lawyers we are largely a self regulating
profession and we need to do a better
job of that the vast majority of lawyers
Tucker are good people and they're
committed to the rule of law
our judges are lawyers I think by and
large of my experience are good people
but at given the sensitivity of the
position given the importance of the
position of lawyers one bad apple or a
few bad apples can wreak havoc in the
system we do that that is totally
regulating inclusing yes nicely put mr.
Larsen thank you for joining us my
pleasure Thank You Tucker